foreign
okay Jacob barhog is an independent
computational disease modeler focusing
on machine comprehension of clinical
data the reference model for a disease
progression was self-developed by Dr
barhak the reference model is the most
validated diabetes model known worldwide
and also the first covid-19 multi-scale
Ensemble model his efforts include
standardizing clinical data through
clinical unitmapping.com and he is the
developer of the micro simulation tool
or myth Dr barharc has a diverse
International background in engineering
and Computing science he is active
within the python community and
organizes the Austin evening of python
coding Meetup for more information check
back on to the Meetup page and then he
has a link
okay
okay can I start uh yeah okay I'll pass
it off to Dr barhok and then yeah any
questions you can feel free to interrupt
so I'm going to talk about the reference
model for this progression but now for
covert 19. uh they
representation the presentation itself
is interactive uh you can actually go
and
uh if you want you can there's the QR
code that will lead you to it you will
see it says chronic disease infectious
diseases in Paris France last month well
this was the keynote there in that
conference
um
and I'm going to repeat more or less the
same presentation but hopefully it will
be more interactive and you can ask
questions and I will add a few more
things just to to absorb what what is
the work is all about so this is the
let's model and it explains what it is
it's in
simtk.org this is where modelers once
the sites were modelers put the models
on or advertise their models and there's
a lot of information about it and
historically I'm going to go from back
this is how the reference model started
what is the reference model I was
modeling diabetes and noticed there are
many many models in many populations and
the models are not always good for each
population so I started by making them
compete
and this Matrix kind of shows models
against populations and shows you what's
good what's bad this was 2014 and then
it's actually the 11th monster 2012 but
2014 or 16 are still doing Matrix in 17
I started making the models collaborate
it's how diabetes model looks like the
diagram I'm going to show it later and
within time the diabetes model grew up
to the points that in 2020 it was the
most validated diabetes model that was
ever made I just I started adding more
and more information into it and then
came the pandemic 2019 I present in a
condacon you can see there's a good
presentation that shows what it is to
data and more or less this is what
things were in 2020 and then the
pandemic hit
if you can see how he's the head of
Midas uh these days uh Midas is a group
that organizes all the people that deal
model infectious diseases and uh you can
see this in 2021 I already presented
something there
and this is what I'm going to tell you
about what I present I actually created
the model for covet so let me show you
how things were before this is diabetes
model this is what was there before this
is before
and then uh this is how a diabetes Model
results look like clinical trials where
you can see the names of names or
acronyms of clinical trials or clinical
trials almost have acronyms they in
fundament sometimes they all become
words those acronyms so and then you can
see some results so this is the diabetes
model that was the reference model and
what it does it makes many many models
like Mi models stroke models and
mortality models
this is what was into in 2020 actually
this was supposed to be uh presented at
the NIH but then pandemic hit and all
was canceled meaning all conferences
were canceled everything became online
so this is a remnant of what was
supposed to be a poster there and never
and it became something online
and now
with the pandemic hit people started
asking me oh you're a computational
disease model what you have to do with
the say about covet and at that point
not much because chronic diseases are
kind of different than uh infectious
diseases and chronic disease the person
has disease and it
basically interaction that other people
doesn't change anything it's like the
disease progresses in that person so the
modeling is kind of different because
there are the interactions between
people
covered or infectious diseases one
person infects another still the disease
progresses within that person but still
there can be no infection and stuff like
that oh my tools were not ready for that
it took me a few months to actually
change the tools to be able to adapt to
uh um infectious diseases and today and
then I created uh I published in cursed
the initial use case this is the
publication you can find it
this was in July
in July 2020 then later I got some more
uh information I got some support for
computing power my model takes a lot of
computing power we'll talk about it a
little bit later
and uh I published an interactive again
I'm using all of this technology for all
the interactive stuff you'll see so this
is an interactive paper you can find it
either through this DOI at the top or
you can just Google it's on my GitHub
account here
and um
this is where uh the reference model was
created The multi-scale Ensemble model
so there aren't that many Ensemble
models from a covenant team but none of
them is multi-scale I'm going to talk
about it in this during the talk why why
is it a little bit different and it is
different than other ensembles you found
in the past because in this Ensemble the
idea is for the model to actually
understand what's going on
my purpose in working and this is what
the talk will be today is I'm trying to
apply the reference model to explain the
data that we saw in the US many models
try to forecast what will be in the
future they call it predict but you
cannot really predict and focus thing is
very hard especially if you don't
understand all the things that you are
modeling
so what I'm trying to do is I'm trying
to take uh intelligible models models
that you can explain what they are and
merge them together and using machine
learning techniques and a lot of
computing power put them together into
something that you can later explain
someone what's going on with covert 19.
in ways that humans can understand it
and I'm showing it visually I'm using
all of this technology to show this uh
so
let's dive into covet
unless you have questions by now which
could just interrupt me
um
if we're talking about the activity if
you hover in this presentation you can
press tabs you can hover over things all
of this is only written in Python
everything I do is python pure python
So eventually it becomes an HTML file
but it's all python so you can actually
find references and see exactly what
information I used and if you click on
them it will take you to that reference
but let's talk about covert this is a
diagram of covert
and I'm trying to explain covet in the
U.S the numbers that were reported by
the covet tracking project some of the
members at the beginning there was a
project that reported infections and
deaths in each U.S state and they were
pretty good and they they were pretty
good about it they had the best data I
could find at the beginning of the
pandemic
so when people started bugging me about
what about covet then I started looking
for
there you go so I'll give them
a good good recommendation the covet
tracking
I can actually still probably find
something online they allowed me to use
their data and
um what I'm trying to do is I'm trying
to figure out how people move from
coffee to infected and from covered to
recovered or death uh using all sorts of
models and each one of those words here
in purple this is a whole group of
models infectious I have multiple models
Transmissions I have multiple models
response or sponsors responsive the
pandemic it's behavioral models recovery
well notice the few things about
recovery I'm not modeling the Aero back
of people who recovered get reinfected
why because it's still early in the
pandemic I'm modeling April 2020. they
weren't that many recovered people that
you can actually that this L will make
sense the back L for my cover to
infected but later on we can add this
but still I'm trying to explain the
beginning of the pandemic
um and then of course volatility models
there can be multiple you can move some
things and Beyond everything there's an
observer model an observer model is the
model that corrects all the inaccuracies
that or actually it kind of distorts all
the things like they were reported in
real life like people were claiming that
there aren't that there is infections
are not reported wrong or the depths are
not reported correctly so the Observer
model sorts things the same way that
they were distorted in reality and there
are multiple of those models because
there are assumptions one basic thing is
that the model is not always true the
model is always an assumption and we're
trying to figure out the best best set
of assumptions that actually fits the
data and the data comes from multiple
sources of the project I told you about
but there was also uh Census Data from
the US there is also papers that are
extract to pay information from either
data or models and finally
um I even added temperature data on the
U.S states I I took from NOAA but
there's many many models that came from
different sources and throughout the
presentation to three people
contributing this or that model in the
you'll see a link to wherever it came
from so let's not talk about
infectiousness but before we start
talking about functions this let's tell
you why am I modeling infectiousness
so at the beginning maybe even now I
didn't check lately but the department
of homeless security uh DHS released a
document called the master question list
about the pandemic
you can actually find it probably in
archives it was a government document
that looked over what they know or think
they know about the pandemic they were
quite accurate about how I how
what they think they know in that
categories of we know this we think we
know this and these are the questions
that we want to ask one of the questions
and this is from a document from May 26
this document updated this question
later disappeared they probably either
figured out or figured out this question
it's not what they want but in May 26
they asked the following question what
is the average infections period during
which individuals can trans transmit the
disease
so think about it in the end of May a
few months into the pandemic the
government still
a very good work if you want the
document that explains the pandemic
go and look at this document that they
really did great work I I only can
compliment them but they still didn't
know the answer and partially because
the answer is more complicated than the
question they asked for
here are some models that you can find
on the internet of people trying to
model infectiousness uh
and and I took the references you can
find out here some of those models I I
made some liberties with them I made
some corrections some of them I had to
copy by hand but you can see the
different people or different modelers
sometimes it's like they took
information about one infection server
person sometimes it's models or model of
the disease and you see the models
become different all of them here are
normalized so you will see uh if it
actually they count according to the
maximum uh shedding of the virus which
is considered one they will you see the
relative shedding of the virus for each
day since infection Day Zero is the
infection then you can see
later how it progresses so
you can see if I change the infections
as different people
have different infections curves which
is one the correct or which is the
average one
that's the question the model will
attempt to answer but what it will
actually do it will take all of those
into account because it's an ensemble it
allows you to take multiple models and
model them all together
then um the next type of category of
models or transmission models which ask
you uh if you encounter a person what's
the probability of actually uh the
person has covered what's the
probability of you actually Contracting
that parent counter this is the number
in percentages it may seem low and I'm
actually well I was very surprised about
it however
um and in the beginning when the first
publication I found that it was like 0.6
by but the numbers there were a little
bit uh
um underestimating the pandemic so
later on I found out it's more about two
percent the numbers you see here if
you're feeding higher numbers then the
numbers don't fit you the epidemic
spreads too fast
so
this has to do with multiple factors
this is only for one encounter but
remember
the other there are other things that uh
um that affects the disease like number
of encounters which is not part of the
transmission model but population
density is uh some states have higher
population that may affect the
transmission those random elements like
people coming out of state and therefore
they were not part of the state
population but it still affects people
so it's a random elements that you add
and finally at some point I noticed that
the temperature uh
them so some states had numbers that
were way off and we figured maybe it was
something to do with temperature so we
had the temperature because both viral
survey survivability and
and the human behavior affected by
temperatures some called those States
some other some other states so models
two and five here
each role here is a model so model
student5 have elements that have to do
with temperature effect by the way they
they contradict each other so if they
have the same influence they should
cancel each other out so these are
assumptions about how transmission
happens and we'll see later how those
behave
but one thing the element that is
missing within this transmission model
is the response model a response model
is human response to that pandemic this
means Behavior human behavior
so
I'm modeling the response model how many
interactions people have compared to
what they had before how the number of
interactions changes
how do you do this well you can take
estimators like apple Mobility data
so Apple mobility looks at how much
people look at their phone and they
click on the map app and then we call
this for the entire population of the
states uh they provide you the
information for each day so this is one
estimator and I took two models that
changed the variable that use that in
some changes model number three is for
people and I believe you know people
like this who ignored the pandemic said
no I'm gonna not gonna change my
behavior because of the pandemic I know
a few people like that
and I heard others people also saying so
there are some people like this so this
is model number three model number four
and five this is Eric Ferguson uh
actually this is me taking Eric Ferguson
data Eric Ferguson Montclair University
he published information he did an
analysis of one stage
here this reference what I did is
[Music]
I thought he sent me
for whereas calls and bars and
restaurants open or closed in
non-essential shops and so on and so
forth and
each state had different measures so
this affects the behavior of people in
different states so model four and five
say people comply with those measures
fifty percent of the time or ninety
percent of the time those are two
different behaviors and this will change
the number of people you interact with
to people only in your household or only
all in the amount of people you usually
interact with
so all of those evaluations of how
people behave and just like in society
people behave differently each one of
those models will represent a part of
society when we model things
finally
if we have infectious transmission no
responsible we can actually calculate
how many people get infected but after
they get infected some people die so
mortality model is kind of complicated
uh how they are constructed I'm going to
show it to you visually
so this is how uh volatility models look
like this is a probability
of dying according to age according to
your age this is the person will die but
we don't know when the person will die
and this is important we start in
comparing numbers because the person
starts getting infected eventually they
will die at some point if they die
so I gathered some numbers did some
calculations and assumed this is
gaussian and or or some variation of
calcium
and uh this is when people will die
so this is for multiple sources however
this is not a good enough model I want
actually to know at any day what's the
probability of a person dying in this
case this is where came Felipe castillon
probably actually made my model uh not
only him but his example was very good
made my model and multi-scale Ensemble
mode what's a multi-scale Ensemble
what's multi-scale multi-scale is when
you model what happens at the cell level
or even before this before this is the
molecular level and the cell level at
the organ level then in the human level
one a person level and then at the
population level if you have different
scales scales and you cross scales
so he actually crossed scales he was
modeling how cells would die
a cold and then the organ will die at
some at some point at some cutoff level
and then the person dies and he was
basically modeling the propagation of
the virus within the cells
and he can give me because he was
modeling this he was actually able to
give me an equation that looks like this
that for a certain age
for a certain time you can find the
probability so uh a person at age 60 at
day 20 has about
point four percent dying on that
specific day if they have covered of
course
this is according to his model and 90
it's about one percent it's day 21
something like that
but remember a person may die there's a
percentage of him dying each year and
you can see this uh probability density
function this was a very good model to
plug in and it made my model multi-scale
Ensemble because I now
incorporate models that will operate on
different scales
finally once you have the mortality
model you can calculate how many people
are infected and how many people died or
you can think you can calculate then you
come to the point that you compare those
results with the actual results that you
obtained from the copy tracking project
and I have those results already I'm not
trying to predict the future or Focus
the future what I'm trying to do is I'm
trying to make the results match all of
those models that make sense and we can
understand what they are I want the best
combination of them that will match the
data
so this is where it becomes tricky
because the data is dirty
we don't know how dirty it is sometimes
so we have to throw away assumptions of
experts that will tell you how well it
is and this is the Observer model The
Observer model
s things as if the difference between
what actually happened and what was
observed what The Observers saw so
Observer model or number one the
simplest one says for
infections or mortality the numbers
reported are correct meaning whatever
coffee tracking project told you about
how many positive tests there were and
and how many uh deaths this is the true
numbers this is the
uh this is what you should match to
however model number two and most people
think that uh you have to those numbers
are skewed uh you can multiply the
number of infections by five you don't
have to change the number of deaths
because depths are kind of harder to you
know tweak if someone died then yeah you
know they died but you know tests if you
test someone to be covered you don't
always test correctly you don't test
everyone so there's more variability so
one number two and three says say
multiplied number of positives you have
by five or by 20 model number three to
actually uh model the correct number
One Number Four came from uh Lucas
botcher he uh he said that the number of
deaths
is something that has to be corrected
and he has a publication about it he
actually sent me a table of Corrections
he also said multiply the infections by
7.15 and the number of deaths well it
varied per state some days it states
were marked out some were less accurate
he did the work I just took his words
for granted model number five well this
one's interesting
this one I said you know what after we
did one simulation we know what the
numbers we got and we know numbers what
you should have got let's create a
correction that by average will correct
it and we'll just plug it in just to
make the numbers right
this is kind of like cheating because I
I already know what I was supposed to be
and I'm trying to fix my number so
apparently if ever if I'm correct and
everything I'm saying is correct the
model number five should give me the
actual the best model because I already
know what I should correct to correct it
for let's see if it actually happens
real life is actually much more
interesting than this let's look at the
results
so the results that you see here were
computed and by the way I have many sets
of them I have more than 100 simulations
by now even more than 120 and I have 58
versions of the model I've been working
on this for about two years each
simulation I do takes weeks days depends
on what it is
this simulation took about three weeks
to compute these days is how much it
takes because I'm running heavy
simulations uh think about it it's like
three and a half years of computation on
a single chord but I'm using 64 cores to
actually run this
uh why because what I'm doing is I'm a
running simulation of 100 000
individuals for each state think about
the 50 states or money like five billion
people
uh
and actually in the simulation I'm
running 48 states I I won't go into
details why some of them don't have some
missing data
um
so but then you have to repeat the
simulations like many times because each
simulation is different just like in the
world if you repeat the same process it
doesn't it's random it'll be different
so I do it another I do it more and more
and more and then I have to up run it
for all the models and I have to
optimize it meaning running with
population so all of this takes time one
iteration takes about two days for each
simulation I'm running it's like five
minutes
so the five minutes go to like a huge
number because I'm running so many of
them I use Python tools to do this uh I
use dusk I use very good tools let's
look at the results
so
the results uh look like this at the end
I gather everything and then so I can
show it not wait
situation what happens
this is where the slider here here does
and um
if you look at this plots on the upper
left uh this represents what's going on
each circle here you see there are many
circles sometimes they overlap each
circle represents one time stamp
or the simulation so you're starting
from April 1st 2020 and this is day 21
meaning this is April 22nd 2020 in New
York
this is New Jersey let's look at New
Jersey for a second
the height of the circle represents the
error I want all of those circles to be
near zero this means I have a perfect
model
but tell me how to get there it's it's
far and it's random data it will never
be perfect but we at least we want to
improve it as much as possible to get
insight on how the disease behaves
so
the let's look at the number called
observed infected this is the number
that I'm trying to match to the number
after the slash the model is the number
before the 324 is number before the 10th
the 1076 is number after this is what
was seven thousand seventy six is what
is reported by the copy tracking project
out of 100 000 people for that day in uh
in New Jersey I'm trying to match it and
you see it's way off at the beginning
like 300 now it's a bad model number of
observed deaths also it's like way off
so this is why the circle is very high
because the errors in both of them are
are high uh and what I'm trying to
optimize or the error I call it the
fitness score is kind of a combination
of both of these it's almost Edition but
not exactly the equation is a little bit
uh more complicated
so what I'm trying to do is I'm trying
to get all those circles to zero and how
do I do it I change the mixture of the
models at the beginning of the
simulation all models have the same
influence
we know what the models are we know how
the world should be even or assume how
we behave and now we're at the beginning
we don't know all the experts they call
those things we don't know which one's
better or not so what we do is say okay
we believe you the same and this is
why you see all those blues the blues
are infection models they have all the
same influence all about 20 this means
about 20 of the population behaves like
one of those
infectious course like this 20 like this
20 and so on and so forth
so then there are transmission models
the response models the dev models of
the high one they'll combined
complicated this is why they're high I
won't go into details and observer
models that I think you should be in
what I do is I ask when I run the
simulation for one each one say okay
what if you were more influential what
will happen
and then I run the simulation and you
run gradient descent algorithm and it
tells me oh you know if this model was a
little bit better
then the results will be like this and
notice
similar the circles have dropped so
results became a little bit better and
then a little bit better and now
intuition then a little bit more better
and you can see the average and the plot
here or the bottom this shows you all of
the components this is kind of like the
average of whatever you see here the
weighted average you see here
considering the size of the state it's
about other factors sometimes
and
if you continue in simulation you find
your own single uh
iteration nine
you get the best results and notice New
Jersey now is much much better we're
like 866 to 1000 infections not that bad
and the number of deaths is like well
sixth off it's not much better than it
was before
this is what the reference model does
now let's look at all of those uh
models again and you can see
the infectiousness model that had a long
set covered is long and it takes a long
time to to infects a lot well it was
very influential while models that are a
short infection
not very influential this means probably
covered
as infectious for a long time this is
the answer for the VHS the transmission
model that is dominant is the one about
two point something percent but if you
combine them all the transmission is
like two percent per person
a per encounter not per person per
encounter
uh and then
models two and five they seem to be not
very influential but also they are not
very different than each other this
means temperature doesn't have a lot to
do with coverage
and we tried we tried to model C but it
might have some influence but it's very
mild
people apparently the estimator of Apple
Mobility data seemed to be pretty good
because it actually the models that says
oh people behave like Apple mobility is
very good only about 10 of the
population uh ignore ignored covet and
some people but not that much uh
followed the instructions uh they give
by uh they gave in the uh
they gave by this for each state but it
seems that
and remember some of those models kind
of like oh
like also big
eliminate each other very quickly but
it seems that Apple Mobility data is a
good estimator of how much people
interact with each other
the castilloni mortality model seem to
be very
uh very dominant this is good news this
means we might want to have more models
like this in the future maybe more
multi-scale models to compute the
mortality better
and you remember the story I told you
about
The Observer model they added it should
be perfect this is model number five no
it's the same as everyone else
apparently observation Observer models
don't have much influence here
and I cannot explain it fully now I've
been to working on two years I have a
hunch and the hunch is what we're
modeling is something exponential in
nature almost exponential the this is
the beginning the spread of the disease
while those Observer models are just
correct by something linear they
multiply something
maybe there's something wrong with them
and maybe this is why they're like
you're trying to
model something exponential with
something linear maybe this is why they
don't influential but maybe something
else it may be even a bug and I found
bugs in about two years of working so
and then I've eliminated many of them
so uh whatever I'm telling you here you
have to take with the grain of salt this
is the best I could tell you about after
two years of modeling it doesn't mean
it's ground true because I'm still
working on this and ask me in a year how
well or uh how well it looks like
um
this is you remember infectiousness then
VHS what was asking is by DHS apparently
iteration number nine this is the best
combination of the models that I created
that probably explains best according to
all the data and all the computations I
put in the model
so far this curve is actually the answer
the DHS would have gotten if I had those
tools ready or in the future if there's
a future pandemic and we want to figure
out how infectious it is
this tool can be used by only Gathering
statistics and figuring out this curve
from those elements
um what and at this point I won't bore
you too much you didn't you weren't
asking too much questions but um
uh I want to conclude so everything I
told you has to be taking the grain of
salt I've been modeling this for two
years and I've made mistakes in the past
like uh I thought that the transmission
was 0.6 my first publication now I found
it's more like two percent talk to him
in a few months I might change my uh uh
what I'm saying but this these results
that you're seeing has been stable for a
few months now so I'm probably on to it
but I still have to make sure that the
numbers match not only April the match
may they match June and so on and so
forth this means more simulation it
means a lot more computing power a lot
more work then we'll know more so the
more information you have the better it
is but I'm trying to figure out what
would the government or someone wants to
know but pandemic will know after about
a month of data
and if we know that and it is helpful
then the next pandemic will have a tool
to help
um there's some information about what I
use the python tool I use in someone to
produce both information I have to
acknowledge many people who helped by
providing a
a help of
options giving me models giving funding
for also institutions giving me funding
for computing power uh there are so many
of them and this work maybe I'm signed
on it but many people did contribute and
did help this make happen even by
hosting my server it takes a lot of
electricity even death was helpful
and since I'm a sole proprietor I have
to add the conflict of interest
statement so you'll know where the money
came from for this so I've been funding
this project most of the time I do have
to to
uh two patents on it uh so anyone is
interested in using this technology in
the future uh and there in the US they
better talk to me and uh I would love to
have this technology used by someone big
entities smaller uh I would like more
people
so I'll conclude at this point and open
up for questions if you have any
yes I
I with covid-19 we had have like many
many
um I don't know the name like variants I
mean we have homicron and so how that
impact on this model
so this model is talking about April
2020.
even if there are variants it wasn't it
wasn't dominant or that there was
basically one covet at that point also
remember I I'm not modeling the
infections because there were not that
many people infected so it's a simple
case the idea is that in the future I
can complicate this case more and more
and more and more and with more and more
computing power I will be able to
eventually explain the disease
and here there are some caveats remember
the data I have is dirty the assumptions
are not always correct there are many
things that I may not be able to do I'll
actually show you one of them this is a
this is the result set that I'll get in
yes a few days ago uh I think a week ago
something like this
this is examining the same April but
here I'm looking at the different
Fitness score now I'm almost I'm saying
almost not because not the entirely
correct I'm almost ignoring in fraction
data I'm only looking at Dev data and
I'm trying to optimize just to match
almost only definitely they were very
slight influence of infection
and when I do this you can see the
system Almost Doesn't optimize anything
and the results are slightly different
so does it indicate that the dev data is
incorrect remember I'm talking April so
all of those numbers are small there was
not enough to accumulate by at that
point so those are the lots to model in
a sense maybe this is something that
also have to be taken into account but
I'm trying and I'm showing you that well
it doesn't really converge it's kind of
like fluctuates on the same thing it
does some changes here and you see the
models are slightly different than what
we had before
but
it but this simulation doesn't seem to
improve anything so do not forget to
really improve maybe it's because I
didn't have enough computing power maybe
there's something else blocking it in
the past I had a bug that would block
this right away I removed that bug and
now it's better but like but now it's
not converging so it's like why it's not
converging well maybe it's because the
numbers are too small and at that point
in time when I try to model it with the
amount of data that it's it's
insufficient
maybe we'll see in the future I'll try
when I add more and more and more data
little by little will become better and
better and better
so but did you answer your question
yes yes thank you
any more questions
uh well also about the
Fitness
um
yes for some cities like
um
New York and L.A
yeah so here New York let's take this
point so the fitness score here it
became better this is
54 but it should be twice so it's like
way off the model the beginning the
assumptions I added the beginning to try
to explain what's going on didn't didn't
add up correctly the model was terrible
but later when I improved it by upon the
position got to the point that's like in
iteration nine I think it's the best
result it got it to almost point on
compared to what it started with like
1400 it's a little bit overestimating
out of but it should be 1300 and the
number of deaths is uh 90 again a little
bit overestimating should be 78.
so it started underestimating in the
overestimating but if we go and look at
one more iteration you see it goes up
again you see the model at this point
starts fluctuating it says that there's
a conflict between New Jersey and New
York and some of that so I will show you
you can see when on one goes up the
other one goes up so it's trying to fit
in all of those models to exactly fit it
but all of those changes are relatively
small compared to what we saw in the
beginning if I had much more computing
power then maybe we can run it for much
more to be much more accurate but
remember all of those simulations are
a random and we're modeling a random
occurrence
what what we saw it's like if the
pandemic will hit again it will may not
be the same thing as we saw before we
saw him during the pandemic like
different states starting behaving
differently all around the world so I'm
trying to
find some sort of average in something
that fluctuates all the time so putting
more computing power I'm not sure I'm
even modeling something which is
accurate like the numbers I'm getting
are dual represent the phenomena maybe
it's some sort of L that I'm trying to
model at this point
so I'm I'm not sure I usually stop after
a few iterations but even in iteration 4
you can see you already see
this is where things are stabilizing
more or less Generation 4 is almost the
same as nine you can see New York and
New Jersey are much better than you were
before
here you can see New York is
overestimating again but it's much
better before
yeah do I make sense
yes but I was also thinking that maybe
this is uh actually a problem with this
Source probably I mean how they were
reporting the cases because as far as I
remember uh
the cities were the most impacted by
covet so maybe they didn't
record properly
the cases this is where the Observer
models should kick in you remember I
told you the Observer who's correct
between the number that is actual and
what is reported The Observer The
Observer model should do that but the
Observer models don't budge you see it's
like they don't as if they don't
influence anything I'm still I'm still
baffled about it this is currently what
I have talk to me in a few months maybe
I'll figure out why but like currently
my hunches that even if you give it here
I had models though that you have to
multiple the number of infections by 20.
it is the same as influence is the model
that says no the numbers are correct
so something goes off I don't know why
like it doesn't influence anything maybe
because the things that really influence
the pandemic is the transmission this is
these are models the infectiousness like
how infectious it is maybe they have
much more influence and we just didn't
get there
I'm not sure I'm finding hunches at this
point but you baffled as much as I am
but this is the best I could explain the
pandemic up to about two years of work
so
with the best tools I think that our
best but that's me saying
okay thank you
thank you
if there are no more questions maybe you
should adjourn
yeah I think that sounds about right
um let's have a little thing to read at
the end
okay
okay
okay well uh thank you for coming
tonight and we'll have another meeting
coming up uh
I believe in this oh yeah no next year
this is the last this is the last
meeting of the year
um yeah well thank you for coming and
thank you for giving such an interesting
talk
um yeah it was really good nice meeting
you
yep the same here
um it was a pleasure thank you for the
nice audience
good questions
thank you
okay
have a good one bye-bye when you upload
this video make sure to edit the part in
the middle yeah just take it out
okay
bye bye bye bye